Okay, welcome everyone. I had a lot of nice things to say about our two
speakers today, Ryan and Remus.
They are outstanding and world-renowned in their
specific areas of expertise, but when I looked at the
agenda this morning, I only have one minute to introduce this session.
So instead of saying nice things about them, I'm going to say
nice things about this session. One is that this first
slide shows this little QR code. If you have questions
during the talk or if you're online and you have questions
and you want to write in your questions, you can use that QR code to write in
your questions. But if you're here, we do have two mics in the
room and please come to the center mics to
ask your questions. And we were going to do this, we can do it in a couple
ways, but the way that we've set it up is to have each one of us,
after we give our talk, there's going to be about 10 minutes worth of
Q&A. But at the end, if there's time left over,
we can come back and rehash anything that you might think about on any of the
talks. So with that, my time is up. So I'm going to turn it
over to Remus, and if you can introduce yourself, that would be helpful.
Hi, I'm Remus, Senior Scientific Director at Miltenyi Biotec, and that's my
asterisk and my conflict of interest.
I also have an adjunct appointment out at the Johns Hopkins School of Public
Health. So this is about CAR Ts. We're going to get the CAR T rolling.
We want better, stronger, faster, and smarter CAR Ts.
Now, how can we make them better? First of all, would be to optimize the membrane
residence and signaling of the glycoprotein that is the CAR
molecule. We'd also like to optimize how we interact with the binding
sites on the CAR target, as well as increasing the breadth of the targets
the CAR T cell product is able to see.
On the other side, we also want better cells.
We want to selectively program the cells that we want, like T stem cell memories
or alternate cells, which I think Trent's going to convince you are really
important.
Stronger cells means that they're exhaustion-proofed.
We've known through genetics and epigenetic programming that we can make better,
longer-lasting CAR T cells, as well as decreasing their terminal
differentiation. So that process is often termed metabolic
engineering or signal engineering, and this is in the simplest
manner accomplished when we use kinase inhibitors in giving metronomic
kinase rest, and a lot of work's done by Evan Weber, who's now at Penn,
who has a really great paper recently describing that.
To make faster CAR, it's all about manufacturing.
That's manufacturing faster, both ex vivo, para vivo, and
then directly in vivo, which I think Ryan is going to hopefully have something to
talk about today. So smarter CAR T cells means increased
specificity. This can be given by having a gating mechanism where
A plus B equals one
single readout, and that becomes more and more difficult as we become more and more
entrenched in getting through the different parts of the body.
We also want decreased toxicity. One way to decrease the toxicity is
by modulating interferon gamma pathways.
Marcella Maus has done a great service to the field by showing by
altering how we secrete interferon gamma from our effector cells when we actually
bring down all the toxic sequelae.
Armoring is another way to make a smarter CAR.
We can armor against negative signals.
We've known we can soak up TGF-beta from the tumor microenvironment from
work done in Baylor for quite some time now, but Shannon Oda has been
leading this part of the field by showing us that we can re-engineer PD-1, FAS,
and CD200 to make them intracellular positive signals, not
negative signals, to the engineered T cell.
And we want to not just have payloads that interact with the target, but also with
the tumor microenvironment.
What I think is a largely neglected part of this field that we have to keep
developing is understanding the mechanisms of CAR T cell resistance, especially
in terms of cancer. Inherent CAR resistance via epigenetic stem cell
signatures is really important. We're giving futile therapy to some of our
patients that we know that their CAR T cells are not going to do anything against
that leukemia or that lymphoma. Katherine Massey and Javed Khan have nice papers to
that effect. Acquired mutations and cell pathways have been described by the Penn
group, and antigen loss variation and decreased expression of antigens are also a
common mechanism we need to engineer around. So this is the CAR.
It's a glycoprotein, and it's also the synthetic biologist's sandbox.
There's so many different parts of this molecule we can play with in order to
improve the CAR T cell functionality. I said that word instead of function.
And the extracellular aspect, we have the scFv.
That's the binding portion that interacts with the target cell.
We've worked with scFvs that are derived from antibody molecules, as well as
VHHs from library screens, so that's single-chain binders, whether they're derived
from llamas, alpacas, or nurse sharks.
And then there's the hinge domain.
The hinge domain isn't super variable throughout the field.
We gain them usually from CD8, but the hinge can also come from CD28 when
we're going into CD28 transmembranes, or what's often preferred in Seattle
is immunoglobulin. Really, I call it the tight knot that's created there
with lots of prolines and lots of cysteines to actually multimerize the CAR in
the membrane of the T cell that's been engineered to express it.
In terms of transmembrane domains, Robbie Majzner showed us that
CD28 is the best transmembrane for a low abundance target, but we
can engineer lots of different transmembrane domains, and surprisingly,
some of them don't work very well, such as LNGFR.
CD4 doesn't work very good. TNF receptor superfamily does.
That's supposed to be a check mark, not a box, but anyway.
And lots of
engineering goes into what we do on the intracellular signaling side of the
chimeric antigen receptor. The co-stimulation molecules areGathered
primarily from Signal 2, from the T cell biology world, whether it's
CD28, CD137, or OX40, or from more
general innate immune activators such as MYD88, and then the
activation domain itself, which is harvested from the CD3 zeta
chain. The ITAMs can be engineered as well.
And we knew that back from 2009 from the surgery branch, where Zhao showed you that
you can knock out one, two, or three of those and actually have different outcomes
in your different modeling. The other part of the chimeric antigen
receptor, when we think about a CAR receptor T cell
population, is how we armor the CAR.
What else do we insert in that gene expression cassette besides the CAR
glycoprotein? These could be bispecific antibodies secreting by the activated
T cells. They could be enzymes to interact with the tumor microenvironment or
cytokines.
Membrane residence of that glycoprotein is really important because CARs
interact with each other when they're sitting on the T cell surface, and actually,
they can down-modulate each other either during or after activation.
Adrian Long showed us back in 2015 that the GD2 CAR
actually aggregates in the surface of the cell and induces
terminal differentiation, if not exhaustion, of the T cell product.
So we have to be very careful they won't choose SCFEs or other binding domains that
induce that kind of clustering. On the bottom, Bepler et
al. showed us that the CAR and the T cell receptor end up on different places on
the activated T cell villi. So they don't organize the same type
of signaling complex. Jordan Orange also has some nice images of that
as well. And one way that this obviously is going to impact the
field, and the question you're going to get from the FDA when you introduce, "Hey,
I have a new CAR and I have a new CAR product," is do you have cytokine independent
cell proliferation? Because part of this self-association is going to drive what's
called cytokine independent proliferation.
And here's an example from Pei Rong and Alan
Carter at our shop in Gaithersburg that shows in the dotted
lines, these are T cells that have been stimulated and then they no longer
receive cytokines. In blue, we have untransduced.
That means they have no CAR expressed whatsoever.
In red, we have the CD19 CAR. CD19 CAR is always the most benign
CAR. FMC63 is this unique gift of nature that keeps on
giving. Now, in the filled-in symbols, we have what happens when you
keep giving cytokine after that single stimulation event.
So when you don't give a cytokine, by day seven, the most benign
CARs are already calmed down. We have some intermediate CARs shown in
orange and green that it takes about 10 days to 14 days for them to stop
proliferating. And the pseudo signal we're using here for
proliferation is diameter and microns.
It's very easily measured on the right instrument, and you can also get instruments
at the size of the CAR as well. So it doesn't matter which measure you use, the
graphs look identical. And then if you look in the black dotted line, we do have
one CAR that's actually a little bit tricky. Is this good? Is this bad?
Why does it keep proliferating? We don't know for sure, but we're going to find
out. It may have something to do with the intracellular aspects as well, whether or
not the third generation versus second generation CARs keep on activating.
Affinity maturation is often used to improve the targeting of the CAR T
cell. That's,
on paper, supposed to be the mechanism by which we mutate the CDR3
region to make better on and off rates.
But as shown by Abken and Hombach, that's not often what happens.
Sometimes what you're doing is you're changing hydrophobicity and
charge characteristics such that you're increasing the clustering of the CAR T cell
on the surface of the T membrane. So with this upper part...
That's
a reverse. Okay, here we go. So in the upper part with the
NFAT readout signal, you can see by changing the aspects
of the CAR, we get increasing activity of the NFAT reporter, which is not
unlike the increasing activity seen with anti-CD3 and anti-CD28
antibody. Diabody formation is another way in which CAR T
cells start to cluster on the surface of the formation.
That's when you have two immunoglobulin molecules next to each other and the heavy
and the light variable regions interchange.
Now, this is really important in the antibody world.
When you have to make batches and batches of bispecific antibodies or recombinant
antibodies, what they can start to do is cross-link to each other and precipitate
out, and you lose your product. Well, that same process happens on the surface of
the T cell if it's not engineered properly.
If you don't have the right spacers and linkers, you start to get interchange
between the heavy and light variable regions, and the CARs can cluster by this way
also. We know that the CD22 CAR M971 does some
diabody formation. I'm not telling you if that's good or bad.
The jury is still out, but it certainly does happen.
Our own experience with this little dive on association
and clustering started when we started to make some anti-BCMA CARs.
As you know, BCMA is a great target for multiple myeloma, and we have
some alpacas running around Germany that needed to be immunized with BCMA, and
so they were done, so we could harvest their cDNAs.
And we made our own VHHs. And what do you use as a control?
Well, Cilta-cel is the gold standard. It's the most used clinically.
And we created our own Cilta-cel-like CAR T cell.
I say Cilta-cel-like because those are their binders that were published, but
that's not their backbone, and that's not their signaling, just to be clear.
We're just examining what happens with the VHHs.
And what you can see in the center part of this is that
interferon gamma, TNF alpha, and IL-2 are
secreted by the Cilta-cel CAR just by sitting in the tissue
culture dish. So it clusters and activates itself to produce these
cytokines. We split the Cilta-cel into two VHHs, and it's
primarily VHH2 that induces this self-activation by the
cytokines. We were fortunate to know this knowledge and know how to do the
screening so that we could choose one that's just as active in the mice, just as
active in vitro, but doesn't do this clustering. And does this matter?
Well, we know one of the side effects of giving Cilta-cel is
neurotoxicity. Now, there's not a lot of surrogates for neurological
cell lines that can read out toxicity, but using HMC-3, which is a
microglial cell line, we showed that when we co-cultured the
Cilta-cel-like CAR or just the VHH2,
we got cell death in this Excelligence assay with HMC-3.
Excuse me, that's the red and the orange right here.
Whereas the untransduced T cells in our own multiple myeloma specific
BCMA CARs did not do that.In those culture
supernatants was gamma IL-2 and interferon alpha.
And of course, we wanted to see, hey, is this a direct toxicity?
Because we saw upregulation of adhesion receptors, so maybe we're sticking more CAR
T cells, but it also works in Transwell.
So what's happening during this self-association and stimulation is a lot of
cytokine production that's actually cytotoxic to this neurological cell
line.
Okay.
We know they self-associate. We know that we can express large numbers.
Is there something that T cell biology can teach us about how we need to cluster
and how we need to understand the activation of T cells?
Well,
back in the 1990s, everyone thought that T cell memory requires surface
expression of self-peptide MHC complexes. So there's lots of papers.
Here's one from Craig Thompson and Ashton Richarff showing us, hey, you got to have
it there. But then in the 2000s, it was like, no,
survival does not require T cell receptor
expression. You don't need periodic tickling of the T cell receptor.
And here I'm making an
analogy to periodic tickling of the CAR molecule itself.
So it was shown that through TCR, more sophisticated knockouts, we don't
need this type of interaction to keep CD8 T cell memory going long term.
However, CD4 is different. CD4, at least some subsets of CD4s,
do need periodic interaction with MHC and target antigens.
So it's a little bit of a mixed bag whether normal T cell biology
needs periodic stimulation to maintain long-term T cell
memory. What we do know and what we can do from a take home clinical message
was from the plat two and plat three trials that were led and published on
by Colleen Annesley out of Seattle.
And what Colleen showed us is that we can periodically boost
CAR T cells directly in vivo in patients. So how is that done?
So when the apheresis product was taken from the leukemia patient, it was divided
in two. Half of the cells were made into CAR T cells specific for CD19,
and the other half of the
lymphocytes were hit with a gene expression vector just for CD19.
So they're a surrogate for a CD19 positive cell, because if your CAR is working,
you're wiping out the CD19 positive cells.
And what you can see over on the right-hand side is that, hey, this patient had
a huge rise in CAR T cells once they were infused, but they started to
sink really very fast. So if we're starting to lose CAR T cells at three weeks, we
know it's a problem. So then we started to boost with these T-APCs, and you
can see with each infusion of the surrogate T-APC or
surrogate CD19, we get a bump in the CD3 positive CAR
T cells, and we also have tagged the
T-APC, so we can see increases in the peripheral blood as well.
So there must be other ways that we can keep boosting and keeping a type of
memory product going with our engineered CAR T
cell. To turn the page to breadth for making better, faster,
stronger CARs, bispecific CARs were created specifically to address antigen
loss and antigen escape. So Andrey Thomas Tikhonenko showed us
that in the initial CD19 CAR T cell trials, we can
splice out exon one or do other types of mutations where we lose the
binding site, and that's one reason we have CD19 CAR failure.
Eli Jacoby showed us that under really strong immunologic pressures, we
can dedifferentiate certain lymphoblastic leukemias, so they no longer express
those markers and actually they no longer even look like B cells.
And also Terry Fry's trials led us to see, hey, when we treat
patients with CD22 CARs, it's not usually splicing or alternate
loss, it's actually downregulation.
So in the lower right, you can see a patient before CD22 CAR, and here is at
relapse. They no longer have expression of that molecule on their surface,
so they're no longer responsive to the CAR.
We've taken this further, trying to construct series of tandem
CARs. Now they can be tandem CARs with CD20 stacked on
CD19 recognition motifs, followed by the
transmembrane from CD8 and then 4-1BB and zeta signaling.
Or we can create new generation, which we've done, that are human binders,
anti-CD20 and anti-CD19 derived from human cDNA
libraries linked to BB zeta. We can create third generation
CARs that has BB zeta N28, or you can do a bicistronic or a
duocar approach where the entire chain is separated by p2A, and you have two
glycoproteins encoded by one lentiviral vector.
Now, we did the first in human tandem T cell CAR trial, and
it's called zamtoscel, hopefully to be approved soon.
And as you know, imitation is the best form of flattery.
And J&J saw this and said, "Hey, we need to acquire some technology from
Abelzeta." So they made essentially the same CAR, but has a
CD28 transmembrane, and Kite is following on with a bispecific
product
with two different chains, a duocar approach.
Now, this is important to validate when you make these tandem CARs.
They don't automatically work one after the other.
So we did a standard series where we induced the
Raji cells and then bleed them and image them every week and look for where's the
CAR T cell and how are we doing in terms of luminescence, in terms of the presence.
And what we can see is that all those CARs I showed you on the previous page
control disease really, really well. So that was boring.
But when we rechallenged them, this is our own version of a stress test with some
viable Rajis, we start to see differences in the different
formats. Fortunately, zamtoscel, the old generation mouse
binders, do this really, really well. Our human binders control them as well.
But some of these constructs, just by switching around who has 28 and who has
BB zeta,
you get very different outcomes that are not as strong CAR T cell products.
In terms of AML, my question to the field, and maybe we can discuss this, is
how many AMLs are there? This is a figure from Soheil
Mehshinxhi's paper showing you that pediatric AML is primary
KRAS-driven. Adult has all these NPM1 mutations, and there's a whole
bunch in between. So this entire list are different AML targets that are being
developed by the field. And the question is, all of these, Sar Gill has
some great papers about this, are co-expressed on hematopoietic stem cells.
So can we endure the toxicity while also having our CAR T cell therapy for
AML? In the end, do we need that? If we're going to use the CAR T cell
pre-transplant, if it's part of a transplant package and we're merosterilizing,
perhaps not. The other place where we have to keep expanding and
understanding the breadth of targets is really in
glioblastoma, because glioblastoma is a really heterogeneous
tumor in terms of expression of cell surface antigens.
And Nick Vatanza recently reviewed this in Cancer
Discovery.How do we optimize a
target? Well, we know membrane
proximity is really key to highly functioning CAR T cells.
So Ali Press showed this in 2008, but he didn't have the right binders.
He just had to switch around CD22. Fortunately, Waleed Hassou knew how
to dig through the freezers at the NIH and found M971 and
really definitively nailed that question.
Shed antigen, it doesn't seem to matter until it matters.
And one place where it really seems to matter is mesothelin.
So Ira Pastan and Mitchell Ho have spent a lot of time creating CAR T
cells that bind to only intact mesothelin,
but not cleaved mesothelin. So they're not going to be competed by mesothelin
once it's shed from this molecule.
And mesothelin is shed often because of all the proteasome sites.
Damian Green and Stan Riddell at the Hutch have shown that gamma secretase
inhibitors increase BCMA, making it a better target for
CAR T cells, multiple myeloma, but there's also systemic effects.
It also changes myeloid cells, so it's not really clear what exactly these gamma
secretase inhibitors are doing. And then we can increase the number of targets on
the leukemic target or the myeloma target by
treating cells with epigenetic modifiers or cellular activators.
And Sneha Ramakrishna did a great job showing us that bryostatin really pumps
up the numbers of CD22 on the surface of leukemia and makes it a lot easier to
treat.
Stronger CARs have come primarily from cytokine armoring.
Within the IL-2 family, well, IL-2 is too toxic to the
vasculature. IL-7 seems to always induce splenomegaly in our animal models.
But IL-15, there's lots of approaches.
I could give an entire talk on IL-15, but you'll have to get that information
elsewhere because it's really exciting what's going on.
In the IL-12 family, it's been uniformly viewed as just being too
toxic. We've seen deaths in patients that have received either TIL products or
CAR products that are secreting lots and lots of IL-12.
However, Saul Priceman came up with pretty novel and interesting armoring, in which
his specific CAR T cell also secretes an anti-PD-1
scFv linked to IL-12. And this seems to localize IL-112 in
the right place for activating within the tumor microenvironment.
Within the IL-1 family, IL-18, this has been really, really active.
Carl June published in "The New England Journal" last year that after following
commercial CAR T cell failure, he has a humanized
anti-CD19 that secretes
IL-18 and has a really great
effect as well. You can see that paper.
And then the regulatory modulators such as SISH.
Again, Henrik Abken is always looking at these fantastic model systems.
I like to give you as a take-home message when you're screening your CARs, do a
multifactorial screen just by comparing IL-2 and IL-18
and the induction of TBET and the reduction of FOX01 in either CD4 or
CD8 populations. He was able to show back in
2017 that IL-18 is really something we should be paying attention to, and
concurrently, he also excised the tumor itself and showed that you lost a
lot of CD206, was the M2 macrophage signal within those lesions.
We have our own murine pancreatic carcinoma model.
We've armored RO1 CARs with IL-18 and regulated it with
NFAT-IL18, and they both have significantly better disease control than
RO-R1 CARs on their own. And you can go check out BK Thakuri's
poster on Tuesday if you want to see more information about that.
So the tumor microenvironment, it's complex, it's systemic, it's not just
a huge wall. It's biologically induced.
So in here we have a tumor residing within a mouse.
When we give the mouse CAR T cells, all of a sudden we get this huge
collagen matrix, and this collagen matrix is infiltrated with myeloid cells.
That what we did is we basically, by giving CAR T cells, we changed a tumor that's
immune excluded or cold, excuse me, immune desert or
cold tumor into an immune excluded. So no longer do these T cells enter.
Well, they weren't there in the first place.
And now we've also induced expression of PD-L1.
Peter Sullivan has a great article about showing if we
actively fight against this stromal
formation by inhibiting MIF, IDO1, TGF-beta,
nitric oxide, CSF1 receptor, and myeloid-derived
suppressor cell differentiation with ATRA, then you can actually get effective
control of a tumor that has really low expression of target FGFR4,
but also
is now active. The last thing we want to talk about is optimizing manufacturing.
We can optimize vector titer and vector manufacturing.
There's still a lot of work to do. Just in this year in 2026, in a
Jitsi article, Bruce Levine and Carl June talked about a new vector format that
they can stick in 10 kilobases, including a SynNotch system, into a
lentiviral vector. So we're still not done optimizing how to manufacture
lentiviral vectors and make them have bigger payloads.
We know that we can give fresh T cells.
Nirav Shah in Milwaukee has shown us that fresh T cells work really, really good.
And of course, Mike Malone showed us, wait, we can do this entire thing in one day,
and that led to the T-charge program that's now being developed at
Novartis. Direct in vivo, it's not a free ride.
We're going to have double toxicity from lots of particles and expansion of the CAR
T cells, but Ryan's going to convince you that he has a way around that.
And implantable T cell factories I think are a way that's to come,
whether they're alginate scaffolds developed by Yev Brudno or
hydrogels. These can be loaded with activation motifs,
cytokines, and vector, and given directly into the body.
These then become small little bioreactors that generate CAR T cells.
Really, really fascinating. And this is my last slide.
What are the key drivers keeping the cost high and restricting access?
They're technical, cost of goods, cost of manufacturing, cost of
therapy. They're regulatory. The regulatory aspect of
this, especially for closed systems, is way too high.
It restricts access throughout the developing world. And they're legal.
There's lots of patent issues that need to be resolved, and I look forward to some
of you going to law school and solving some of those problems.
And they're philosophical. I could give a whole lecture on how we price cell and
gene therapies and how we're doing them in an incorrect way.
And you, the audience, are the
inventors. When you make an invention and you patent it, you have the
ability to dictate licensing terms, and you can dictate zero
licensing costs or reduced licensing costs for low and
middle-income countries. And they're waiting for you to
do that. They're waiting for you to reach out.
We have colleagues in Uganda who want to establish a bone marrow transplant unit.
They want to do CAR T cells, but they're blocked by all of these different issues.
So you can be with-King Leopold II and see the developing
world as some place to just extract resources from, or you can be like
David Brittan, who treated the first CAR T cell patient in Africa.
This is Nicodemus. He got CD19 CARs, point-of-care manufacturing,
closed system, and it's a remarkable story.
So cell and gene therapy has arrived there.
We just need to
somehow use our intellect, knowledge, and sympathy to
move it forward. So we talked about the glycoprotein.
We need to study as much as possible. We talked about the CAR T cells.
The T cells are really important. And I would look for an article coming out from
Joseph Mellenhurst at the Cleveland Clinic.
He has great data showing that maybe the most important driver of all of this is
how good the starting T cells are in and of themselves.
I don't know if you heard the ORCA-T lecture from Stanford earlier today, but
they're using
transplant
donor-derived, not patient T cells to do something, which may be one reason why
it's working so well. We talked about armoring and the tumor microenvironment as
well. So I've summarized a huge chunk of data
from some really amazing investigators.
Here's the ones that were in the Miltenyi family, and I'm really grateful for that,
and I'm really grateful to Stefan and also to Mike Jensen and Crystal Makal.
These are three people who have given me incredible freedom to develop these
therapies and to think about them and to develop them.
And I hope that all of you can find these types of environments in which you can
express in a really practical, down-to-earth way these new
insights that we're gaining every day from CAR T cell therapy approaches.
So thank you.
I think I ate up the question time.
You did, but it's important. I was going to knock you off your soapbox,
but I thought, "This is important." So we let you keep going.
If there's any burning questions or you can wait till the end
to ask.
That was like four graduate classes in one. So we appreciate it.
Okay, now for something totally different.
So I'm going to talk about innate cell product engineering.
I'm Trent Spencer. I'm a professor at Emory University,
and I direct a cell and gene therapy program in the Marcus Center for Cellular
Therapies, and a past president and co-founder of a couple biotech companies,
which are listed here. And the interest for
today is introducing
innate cell therapies into our armament.
Now, Marina's just finished talking about adaptive immunity
without saying the word adaptive.
But here he's looking at adaptive immunity, and he's looking at T cells, and
specifically CD4 and CD8s within the adaptive
immune system. Now, there are other education systems, and I'll talk about natural
killer cell and macrophages. So,
for this one, I'm going to talk about this innate bridge cell called
gamma delta T cells. But when I talk about gamma delta T cells, it's
actually,
you can gain a lesson for all of the different innate cells
that you may be thinking about and alpha-beta T cells as
well. So,
when you start thinking about gamma delta T cells, you're like, "Well, most
people have never heard of a gamma delta T cell.
Why would we be interested in it?" Well,
years ago, a friend of mine, Larry Lamb,
discovered that after transplant of allo patients,
those that had the highest
survival were those that had a high
increase in gamma delta cells after transplant.
So that indicated that if you have a robust
recovery in gamma delta cells, you have a higher chance of survival.
So that was one aspect. But then as things moved on, there
are other studies in the gamma delta field, and this study, which was
somewhat agnostic about the cell type, they just looked at what cell types are in
tumors when you have better
favorable outcomes. And what they showed is that gamma delta T cells are on the top
of that list. If you have a lot of gamma delta T cells in your tumor,
it's a predictor of a more
favorable outcome. So there's a couple of reasons to think
about gamma delta T cells. And I know in this field, when you get something that
works, there's a lot of people that jump on it.
And this slide kind of shows all the players that have been doing
this recently, where you have the start and discovery of gamma delta T
cells, and then you take this long road up to
discovery and applications, and then once you have a successful
application, you get a lot of companies that are jumping on this cell
type. So the cell type is maybe not understood
amongst this group, but there's a lot of effort going on in the gamma
delta T cell world for this. So then think about what is a
gamma delta T cell. We heard about the alpha beta T cells and CD8
T cells and some of the armament. And when you look at
gamma delta T cells, this is an innate cell.
It's not going to recognize an
infection. It's not going to
develop an immune response. But what it's going to do is recognize
several different aspects of cells that are under stress or
cells that
have different aspects of non-normal cell
biology. And we're going to look at the gamma delta T cell in a little bit more
in depth in the next couple of slides.
So when you look at the T cell developmentT
cell development is very well known for your CD4 and CD8s, and there's about
another 100 CD4 and CD8s that you can add to this.
But then in the gamma delta T cell, it undergoes its own processing through the
thymus, and then what you end up with are these gamma delta T cells.
And in our instance, you can have gamma delta T cells that
may be T17, gamma delta T1.
These are all important T cells. But when you're looking at a
therapeutic outcome, we're actually looking at a
couple of these gamma delta sources.
Now you can have a delta chain in humans, you can have one through five
different delta chains, and you can have several different gamma chains as well.
And these gamma chains pair with the alpha,
so you have a gamma delta pairing. Now for
this purpose, for our purposes, we have mainly this Vdelta1
pairing and Vdelta2 pairing to delta 9,
is some of the cells that we're interested in.
So although there's all these different
gamma delta T cells that are available for editing and engineering,
these are the ones that are moving through clinical development.
And when you look at this, we have Vdelta1s and Vdelta2s, and there's this
great debate in the literature and in different meetings about which
one should you be targeting. And it's because they recognize different.
The Vdelta1s recognize CD1 family, Vdelta2s
are
phosphoantigens, which I'm going to talk about.
The delta1s are less abundant than the
delta2, so starting with more cells, the manufacturing
is less complex. Predominantly in tissues is the
Vdelta1s. Now this is important because if you're trying to treat a solid
tumor and you want those cells to go back, we know that if you take cells out, you
modify them, they tend to go back to where they started.
And
it's thought that the Vdelta1s might be a little bit better for solid tumors, but
that's certainly a part of this great debate.
And then, the side effects with the Vdelta1,
you're expanding these
similarly to alpha beta T cells. And what Remus didn't mention is that a
lot of times you'll get contamination when you're going after, say, a T
cell or some other
cell types that might be contaminating.
And you also have a potential for graft versus host disease when you're
expanding these. And for the Vdelta1s, you don't have this risk of
graft versus host disease, and which we'll talk about.
So then here's the Vdelta1, the gamma9 delta2
T cells, and these are compared to the alpha beta.
These are considered MHC independent, where you have
recognition through a TCR, the gamma delta TCR, which we'll talk about.
But also these cells are armed with CD16.
They express NKG2D for stress
antigen
expression and to recognize stress antigens.
Then you have FAS ligand recognizing FAS as well.
And then these kill through perforin granzyme.
So not only do these gamma delta T cells kind of bridge between this adaptive and
innate immunity because they will spew out cytokines to help
the alpha beta cells as well, but they kill the tumors
directly, and that's what we're going to talk about here in a little bit.
So here's if we drill down just a little bit more and try and get more basic.
We have a gamma delta T cell that's expressing the NKG2D,
which will recognize stress antigens.
The TCR recognizes phosphoantigens, which I'll talk about in a little bit,
FAS ligand, and then CD16 for
antibody-directed cellular cytotoxicity, or ADCC.
So now if you're thinking about the gamma delta TCR, the
recognition, it's not been that long that we've actually known what the
gamma delta TCR is recognizing. What it recognizes
is butyrfulin on the target cell. If
butyrfulin is being expressed on the target cell, and the gamma delta
is recognizing butyrfulin, but it's not just butyrfulin, it's only
butyrfulin on cells that are
expressing phosphoantigens. So if a phosphoantigen is expressed in a cell,
that's going to bind to butyrfulin, change its conformational change, and that's
what's recognized by the TCR. Now you can upregulate
phosphoantigens by giving a well-known drug called zoledronate, which is a
blocker
on this pathway, which actually increases phosphoantigen expression.
So if you can give cancer cells zoledronate, it will increase
the phosphoantigens and
be recognized by these T cells. So this is a depiction of that,
where a tumor cell may or may not express
phosphoantigen. You give zoledronate, it will have increased phosphoantigen.
It'll bind to butyrfulin, and then that butyrfulin will
undergo a conformational change, and the gamma delta T cell will activate on that.
So this is the recognition of inducing
anticancer, where you can have recognition of stress antigens, where you can give
chemotherapy to increase stress antigens.
You can
add zoledronate to increase phosphoantigen expression so that the TCR will
recognize it, and you can give antibodies so that you can recognize through
ADCC.
So then this is an example of giving a
neuroblastoma model, where all the individual treatments, if you just give
chemotherapy, you give immunotherapy, or you give gamma delta T cells by
themselves or in different combinations, it's only the triple
combination where you give
the three of them is the effect of killing.
So gamma delta T cells, in a way, needs the tumor to be primed
for effective targeting. So this study, we showed that you can
prime that tumor by either an antibody and chemotherapy, and
both are needed to have this superior killing of your
target cancer. So this led to a first-in-human,
first-in-child clinical trial where we're using a combination of
temozolomide, zoledronate, and denucixumab with ex
vivo expanded gamma delta T cells.
And we do this so that temozolomide is a chemotherapy to
induce stress antigens. Zoledronate will induce phosphoantigens
within the tumor, and then denucixumab will bind to the tumor and be recognized by
CD16. And this is a first-in-humana study that
Dr. Kelly Goldsmith is the PI on at Emory University.
But one of the problems is not all donors are equal.
When you start expanding these,
Remus
kind of glossed over that the donors in all of his studies were self, and
here, not all donors are equivalent because these cells don't cause graft versus
host disease. You can actually use, any one of you can be a donor if I have
cancer. So we can take your gamma delta cells,
expand them, and then give them to me because they don't cause graft versus host
disease. So that is very
nice. But not all donors are equal, so the use of an
allogeneic gamma delta T cell is a major goal, but choosing the donor
randomly is a poor strategy. And here is
several donors that we looked at where we have expanders and we have non-expanders.
And when you start looking at the expanders and non-expanders, the
non-expanders, and you just look at something like CD16 for
ADCC, the expanders do have high CD16
expression, and the non-expanders don't.
But if you drill down a little bit deeper, and we expanded this study,
if you look at the expanders and the non-expanders, this was interesting that the
exercisers always expanded. And this is on a college campus, so
if you're a college student and you're exercising, you're likely going to
expand. But if you're not exercising or if you're sedentary,
it's less likely that you're going to expand.
And this is the sedentary versus exercisers expanding the
non-expanders. But there's also this age is also important.
For me, I don't expand well, and I was running marathons at this time,
and I couldn't be exercising any more.
So, I think there's an age component as well.
But some people are figuring that out to do this.
Now, also when you expand a gamma delta T cell, there's NK cells that can
be expanded with this. And in some ways, that's good, because if you look at this,
if you look at a cell population that has high gamma deltas
on this end versus high NK cells on this end, see the
killing of a neuroblastoma cell line, two different neuroblastoma cell lines.
If it's NK dominant, those cells work better.
And if you separate these cells from NK cells from the gamma deltas, the
NK seem to do better, and then you can mix them back together and reconstitute
this same killing. So it seems that the NK cells are doing better than the gamma
delta cells. But if you add dinutuximab, which is an antibody
to ADCC, the two cell populations are nearly
identical when you have gamma delta cells with an antibody.
It is almost identical to the NK killing.
And this is consistent on several different cell lines.
So then if you're thinking about expanding gamma delta T cells, we know that there
is a donor difference. So here we're looking at
lots of different donors from the American Red Cross, where we have donors and
we've expanded, and we can pick just the top donors from those, and we can go back
to the American Red Cross and get
leukapaks from those. Then we can run those through an expansion process
where we can start expanding these cells in
flasks, and then they go into a GRX, and then they can be frozen,
cryopreserved, and then those cells at any time can be thawed and given to
subjects. And now here's one of the keys, is trying to get rid of the alpha betas,
because in this case, although Remus can argue that alpha betas are the gold
standard, in this case, we're trying to get rid of all the alpha betas because
of this graft versus host disease concern.
So in this case, if we look at getting rid of the alpha betas on
day six, we use three different methods to show that they're gone, so we don't have
graft versus host contamination.
But the other thing that we're doing is we're working with Georgia Tech
on expanding these cells in various
bioreactors. And when we're looking at these bioreactors, we're measuring just
about everything you can. We've got every probe and every measurement that
we can take as these cells are being expanded in this makeshift bioreactor.
But we're taking this to advance into large-scale bioreactor
manufacturing. And I think we're learning quite a bit about these cells and what
they need and how we can overcome the biology of these cells not
expanding.
So then the donors are good, but for
biologics, the process is the product, and this is something that we say in the
biologics field, the process is the product.
And for gamma delta T cells, the product is highly dependent on the
process that you use to expand these cells.
So in this case,
John Mayer showed that if you use TGF-beta, which is
interesting that
Remus talked about TGF-beta as a negative impactor of
alpha beta T cells. But in this case, TGF-beta in
the manufacturing process seems to aid these cells.
And this paper didn't make a lot of noise in the field.
It was pretty good. But this paper was actually more intriguing to me.
It was a cytotherapy paper where they used human platelet lysate to enhance in vivo
activity of their CAR Ts. And when you grow these cells in
human platelet lysate, you get very good killing.
And this is interesting. And then if you look at this other paper that shows
what is actually in human platelet lysate, you see that TGF-beta is one of the
major components of TGF-beta. So putting those three things
together, I thought we should at least look at TGF-beta.
And what we found is really intriguing, is we looked
under many different scenarios with and without TGF-beta.
And what we found is that when you use TGF-beta,
this is the other thing that Remus was touching on but didn't directly say, that
the cells that are more effector type
in
clinical settings don't work as well as cells that are in central memory or
stem cell memory or even naive. What TGF-beta does when you're
growing these, it keeps these cells in this central memory
and effector memory phenotype. You have most of the cells coming out of these
cultures that are effector memory and not
terminal effector cells. So, this is an
advantage. And if we look at this, it's similar to that
human platelet lysate paper. It's almost night and day when we use
TGF-beta expanded cells
for in vivo killing of an osteosarcoma
cell line, where if we use TGF-beta, it just works
very nicely in the cell line. These are non-modified cells
also targeting osteosarcoma. Should also
mentionI don't think I showed that CD16,
it's not on this, but CD16 levels are downregulated in these cells.
So you do lose the ADCC component. But as we're going to
show, genetic engineering will replace the ADCC component.
So we have this population that looks good, and one of the
reasons that they work better is because of longevity.
And this is non,
these are cells that are grown without TGF-beta, and these are cells with
TGF-beta. The longevity in vivo is increased, and we can go in
and pull these cells out and look at their phenotypes after this.
And as Rimas mentioned, IL-15 is a
large component in some of these expansions, and we tried it with and without and
don't see a big difference when it's in the manufacturing
process. So what we know is that if we look at these cells, these are
associated with increased CAR T effectiveness for alpha beta T
cells. And I think that's the same scenario with gamma delta T cells as
well. So I think if we can have this more central memory like
phenotype, I think we'll get better results.
But you do lose CD16 in this. So then because we're losing
CD16, how can we decorate these cells?
And what's the best way of decorating?
So this is one thing that Rimas covered. These are the chimeric antigen receptors.
But I'm going to postulate that bispecific antibodies
or bispecific T cell engagers are
equally useful for expression from
gamma delta T cells. So if you express, say, a BiTE that
encodes a CD3 binding region that binds to gamma
delta, and you have a second binding region that binds to your cancer
target cell, this is something that
we'll see how useful that can be.
So then when you're looking at this expansion process with the transduction,
we typically do this on day six, but there's a lot of effort that when
is the best transduction process or optimization?
Rimas was talking about optimizing gamma delta, alpha beta T
cells. But the optimization in this is endless because we are
just beginning to crack the nut on how to use these cells.
So then here's one where we actually,
Kelly Goldsmith, who's running the neuroblastoma, she did a lot of work, and we
worked with her on trying to identify other targets.
And one of the targets in neuroblastoma that we identified was PTK7.
And we looked at this PTK7 with a CAR versus a BiTE in
PTK7. And what we found is that if you look at killing, the CAR and the
BiTE kill almost equally well
when expressed in gamma delta T cells.
And the animal studies show similarly that the BiTE works.
And we've got other studies with osteosarcoma and some other cell lines that
suggest that the BiTE may be a little bit
more effective. So I think the BiTE is certainly worth looking at.
So then I think that any, and I'm glad I left this slide in because Rimas didn't
touch on this. Well, he did, but the need for expression
cassette optimization in today's world is a
need. If you're not doing optimization, I don't think you're doing
state-of-the-art research in this field because AI-based custom
solutions can be easily added to your
transgene optimization where you're looking at open reading frame reductions,
you're looking at CpG depletions.
Tissue specific codon optimization, codons in alpha
beta T cells may not be optimal for gamma delta T cells, so optimizing the
codon use is important. And then RNA sculpting is
important as well. So then this, another example where we're
taking gamma delta T cells, and we're comparing these to
T-ALL to see if there's a gamma delta T cell
signal that we can
use that may not be expressed in T-ALL.
Because it's hard to kill T cells with a T cell.
But in this case, using RNA Seq, we showed that gamma delta T cells are very
different to T-ALL, and we went in and identified actually
PTK7 is highly expressed in T-ALL.
We showed that PTK7 is not expressed in our gamma delta T cells,
but it is expressed in several different cell lines.
So we started using gamma delta T cells with this.
And again, the BiTE, this is neuroblastoma, this is a
T-ALL, and you can see that gamma delta T cells just kill
T-ALL very nicely. So then this is the last example
that I wanted to use because it's not engineering with a BiTE or a CAR, but it's
engineering with drug resistance, where we're taking a patient's T
cells, we're introducing genes that confer drug resistance so that we can
give immunotherapy and chemotherapy concurrently.
And we're doing this in glioblastoma, where we will resect the
brain cancer, and then you fill that brain cavity up with gamma delta T cells, and
then you can give
chemotherapy on top of that, and that seems to be working very well
also, and I'll show that on the next slide.
But these are
also not modified for enhanced activity.
These are just gamma delta T cells
modifiedto retain activity in the
presence of chemotherapy, where you get the
drug-induced stress of the cell. And then this is
something that Remus was talking about.
Now, when you do this with gamma delta T cells, it is a desert
of immunity in glioblastoma. With the gamma delta T cells,
when you look at some relapsed tissue, you see that the gamma delta T cells
are infiltrating the tumor microenvironment.
But as they're going in, also when you look at biopsies, you
can see that other T cells like CD3, CD8 T cells are also
infiltrating that glioblastoma as well.
So there's
other potential avenues to add on top of these gamma delta T
cells in this drug resistance phenomenon.
So then the patients, this is the predicted progression-free survival, and these
patients are doing
fairly well. And I don't know the update on this, but they may be
presenting this. So then I wanted to conclude by saying that gamma delta
T cells, they are innate cells, provide multiple weapons and
multiple targets for cancer. The sensing cellular stress with gamma delta T
cells, effector functions, and then the antibody-dependent
cytotoxicity. But then gamma delta T cells have a significant
impact on cancer, as I showed on my first two slides, but then ex vivo expanded
cells can have a significant impact as well.
Now, innate cell sources are being tested, and at least innate cell sources in
several clinical trials. And alternative cell sources such as gamma delta T
cells or immunocompetent cell sources that are being tested
in child and adults, as I showed. And then our thinking is that gamma delta T
cells need to be combined with some sort of conditioning regimen, either
chemotherapy as a whole or some genetic engineering to make them
most potent. And then in general, multiple dosing, because these cells don't
have an infinite lifespan, multiple dosing and keeping pressure on
that tumor is possible using this cell type.
And then engineered cells expressing CARs or Bites enhance targetings, and I think
Bite engineering seems to be promising, and equally promising as
CARs are a useful strategy for increasing gamma delta targeted
killing. Then here's my last conclusion is that
everything in this field is important, and there's lots of
opportunities for optimization, where we're looking at scaling and fold
expansion of the gamma delta T cell, so just the clinical expansion of the product,
Bite or CAR engineering. And there's some IP around, say, Bites and
things around that may not be available for alpha/beta T cells, that
some IP or intellectual property might be available for gamma delta cells.
You have specificity. Expression cassette optimization is hugely important,
and then certainly the genetic modification.
But these that I have highlighted are certain low-hanging fruit that we're
working on. And I did delete my thank you slide, but
with that, I will answer any questions, or we can move to our last
speaker.
Thank you.
And there are no questions online, so we'll move to Ryan.
And as Ryan's coming up here, Remus and I both know a couple people in
his company, and when we ask them to speak, they're like, "Oh, you want
Ryan to speak. You don't want us." So we said, "Okay, Ryan's the guy." So
you're in for a treat.
Thank you, Trent, and thank you, Trent and Remus, for providing really great
overviews and decades of knowledge around cell therapies that we've been
able to leverage and implement in the development of in vivo CAR T
cell
delivery platforms. So by way of disclosure, my name is
Ryan Larsen. I'm head of the research department, an employee at Emoja
BioPharma, and a shareholder. And as I
mentioned, I will be providing an overview of some of the key design elements
of an in vivo lentiviral vector CAR delivery platform
and some of the bells and whistles that Remus provided a nice overview
of that Emoja has implemented in our in vivo delivery platform
that we call VivoVEC.
And I think as we all know,
CAR T cells have demonstrated transformative benefit in
particular in hematologic malignancies.
There's a number of approved products out there,
lymphoma, leukemias, and multiple myeloma, where the treatment
paradigm has really been transformed by those CAR T cell therapies.
Under that current paradigm, there remains a number of challenges with regards
to patient access and experience,
namely vein to vein time, turnaround time, cost, the
requirements for autologous cell therapies to scale out
versus the ability to scale up.
Complex treatment logistics related to having to collect material,
manufacture, and then deliver it to a patient that's been lymphodepleted,
which carries its own number of side effects that can create challenges
for the patient.
And from an in vivo perspective, the intent is to develop
an off-the-shelf product that's immediately available, can be scaled up
readily with low cost of goods approaching what you'd see from a
monoclonal antibody,
enabling a single infusion in a patient that does not have to be
lymphodepleted and can't be lymphodepleted because you need the substrate T cells
to be present. Ultimately,
the goal being that we're able to deliver that same transformative
CAR T cell benefit in a larger patient
population.
So the Emoja team has integrated a number of different
technologies into a single lentiviral vector
delivery platform. Again, we call this VivoVEC.
There's a number of key elements related to the viral vector
itself, as well as the payload that's encoded by the viral
vector. I'll start just by walking you through the mechanism
of action of the viral vector and how it interacts with T cells.
So
as I'm sure folks are aware, in the in vivo cell therapy space,
there's a lot of different approaches to retargeting
vectors or lipid nanoparticles or other delivery vehicles to drive tropism
to intended cell types.Immogia has implemented what we
call a multi-domain fusion protein
alongside the co-CAL fusion glycoprotein that directs
tropism of our surface engineered lentiviral vector particles to T
cells in vivo
and incorporates T cell adhesion, co-stimulation, and
activation components into a single polypeptide.
So we're able to manufacture that in a suspension-based
manufacturing process. What I'm showing you here in this image is actual
GMP product that we're manufacturing in our ongoing clinical
trials.
That is administered intravenously to patients.
These particles, based on the surface engineering, are able to
find T cells, bind in a high avidity manner, and
trigger a series of events that results in durable
integration of the payload into those T cells, expression of
the payload components on the now CAR T cell
surface,
and ultimately redirecting that
T cell to the tumor via the CAR cognate antigen
interaction. In addition to that, we are incorporating an armoring
technology, as Remus introduced, or also known as
potency enhancement technology, that allows us to deliver
selective pro-survival signals to those T cells in vivo in the presence of
a small molecule. This is called the RACR, the rapamycin activated
cytokine receptor, and it delivers an IL-2 or IL-15 like
signal, allowing those in vivo engineered T cells to exist
orthogonally to the endogenous immune system.
Ultimately,
due to the sort of foundational design of this being in a lentiviral vector,
this durable integration in the original transduced
population allows for every subsequent daughter
cell to also express the same payload components, the RACR and the
CAR. As opposed to other approaches to generating in vivo CAR T
cells that employ RNA-based delivery systems and
transient expression of a CAR and payload components.
So zooming in, in a bit greater detail into our
vivovec gene delivery technology.
As I mentioned, we employ the co-CAL fusion glycoprotein.
It is relatively resistant to serum inactivation.
That's why we picked this fusion glycoprotein.
It is displayed
beside our multi-domain fusion, which is an anti-CD3
scFv sandwich with
a membrane proximal human CD80 and a membrane
distal CD58.
As was discussed in some of the previous presentations, patient cells are
often highly dysfunctional. We specifically designed this multi-domain
fusion to incorporate adhesion co-stimulation, engaging
CD2, CD28, and TCR complex
to overcome some of that dysfunctional state that exists in heavily pretreated
patient populations, and to impart important signals
that promote function of the subsequent CAR T cell population.
And importantly, this multi-domain fusion and the components therein
really drive a high avidity interaction with the T
cells. So,
as I'll speak to in the next slide,
again, a similar image, just highlighting
theoretically how these components interact with the T cell, the
particle shown here.
We're able to show both in vitro and in vivo, very rapid and high
avid interaction between the particles and T cells
occurring in less than an hour, and oftentimes within 10 minutes, we can bind
very specific and high avidity interaction between the particle and the T cells.
Another important aspect of
an in vivo CAR T cell technology is the ability to promote a T cell
response in an environment that is
lymphoreplete, so these patients are not lymphodepleted.
And we have found that a key element to be able to achieve that
is to trigger, as best as possible, what looks like a normal
T cell response. So the other aspect of
the multi-domain fusion protein and its components therein is to mimic
an antigen-presenting cell T cell interaction.
And that's really a key aspect of promoting a T cell
response
to an infection or to other foreign antigens,
and we've been able to sort of engineer that into our particle surface.
So we have published on the particle surface
engineering, and I wanted to just summarize some of the data.
We published this in "Blood" a couple of years ago,
highlighting the importance of inclusion of some of these co-stimulatory
and adhesion molecules into the lentiviral vector service,
and compared that to a similar vector particle that only
incorporates a anti-CD3 scFv, so just triggering the
T cell receptor CD3 complex.
And that's shown in red, and you can see very clearly, these are all in vitro
studies on this slide. Very clearly a benefit to
activation after three days of exposure to the
lentiviral vector particles that incorporate the co-stimulatory
molecules compared to an anti-CD3 scFv alone, even at very low
multiplicities of infection. Furthermore, this results in
more potent and robust CAR T cell generation.
Looking here at day seven, both CD4 and CD8 T cells are readily
transduced and enriched over time.
And in addition to that, the resultant CAR T cells exhibit
an optimal polyfunctional profile.
So panels C and D are actually looking at CAR T cell function.
So these are the same
T cells that were co-cultured with the vector here.
The CAR T cells that arise on day seven were then stimulated with
CD19 expressing Nalm6 cells, so
the CAR T cells express our favorite FMC63 anti-CD19 CAR
as a model system. We're seeing here really nice
polyfunctional activity, both as measured by IL-2, TNF, and interferon
gamma secretion
in response to Nalm6 culture, as well as the ability of those
CAR T cells that were generated in the presence of co-stimulatory
molecule-containing lentiviral vector particles to repeatedly
kill Nalm6 tumor cells in a serial cytotoxicity
assay. So relative to those CAR T
cells that were generated with an anti-CD3 scFv displaying particle only.
Again, highlighting the importance of replicating
what is a more native-like immune response with the viral
particle surface engineering.We've expanded
on this data, again, in the same blood publication.
I'm looking at in vivo tumor-bearing humanized mice,
with the same Nalm6 tumor model.
The humanized mice are dosed directly with the viral
particles.
And importantly, the humanized mouse model that we use is an NSG
MHC double knockout background to minimize
background T cell activation from xeno-reactivity to
ensure that we are not overestimating transduction due to
background activation that might arise during the humanization process.
So as best as possible, we're controlling and limiting
the T cell activation to what is delivered by the
particles. And here you can see more potent transduction
with the viral particles that incorporate the costimulatory molecules
in vivo, as well as more potent and durable
antitumor activity in this Nalm6 mouse model, even down to the lowest
dose. So here in the animals that were treated with the anti-CD3 scFv
coded particles only, you see some control, albeit
transient in some animals that don't control at all, versus at all
dose levels,
the costimulatory coded molecules drive a much more potent
and durable antitumor response.
I'm not going to go into detail further into that publication, but
we furthered those studies into non-human primates,
specifically the pig-tailed macaque model.
I want to transition into some unpublished data wherein we've expanded upon that
pig-tailed macaque modeling into a larger cynomolgus
macaque study,
in which we're looking at, in immune competent animals, a delivery of a
single intravenous vivovec dose with a vivovec
particle that encodes an anti-CD20 CAR construct.
I'm looking at both CAR T cell generation as well as B cell depletion
mediated by those CAR T cells. This is an anti-CD20
CAR that's been used historically. It's the Lu16scFv.
They're in clinical trials and/or in modeling of
this more classical ex vivo autologous CAR T cells in a really
nice publication that came out of the Fred Hutch and Seattle Children's
in the late 20-teens. So it serves as a very nice benchmarking
assessment
in terms of the ability of our particles to generate CAR T cells in vivo
with no lymphodepleting chemotherapy versus what's been done historically in the
clinic and also in similar macaque models.
You can see here the design, again, single injection of
the multi-domain fusion coded particles encoding an anti-CD20 CAR,
fully immune competent with no lymphodepleting chemotherapy, no cytokine support,
nothing along those lines.
The design is shown here. In our pig-tailed studies, we
initially leveraged an intranodal or intralymphatic delivery,
for two reasons,
predominantly to
deliver the particles to a highly T cell enriched
area. And also early on, we were worried about
potential biodistribution risks, so we were focused on intranodal delivery.
We've since expanded that to intravenous delivery, and
you can see here in a dose escalated manner,
from five E8 transducing units up to five E9 transducing units.
It allows us to sort of bridge away from the intranodal pig-tailed
studies into our IV based cynomolgus
macaque, and ultimately into our intravenous delivery system that we're employing
in the clinic.
And you can see the schedule of assessments here on the bottom.
So,
right away, just diving into the pharmacodynamic
generation of CAR T cells. You can see here that the single dose of
vivovec particles drove very robust CAR T cell generation
and kinetics with a peak observed between day seven and
10 post vivovec administration.
Generally, in the thousands of CAR T cells per microliter, which benchmarks very
well to previous macaque modeling with lymphodepletion and ex vivo
autologous CAR T cells, as well as what's seen clinically with the current
class of CAR T cells in patients.
You'll notice it's a fairly narrow window of area under the curve.
That's directly related to antigen access
in terms of the circulating CD20 B cells.
So in the next slide, I'll show you very rapid and complete B cell depletion.
Before I get there, I do want to highlight that one of the animals at the low
IV dose had minimal to no CAR T cell generation,
so that's an important point, a reminder for the next slide.
But across the board,
showing representative flow cytometry plots on the right, very robust
transduction expansion and CAR expression observed,
and similar between intranodal, intralymphatic delivery, if not
better in the intravenous
recipients.
So the anti-CD20 CAR T cells are highly functional.
We saw rapid and complete B cell depletion,
again, concomitant to the peak CAR T cell expansion around day seven to day
10, with the exception of the one animal shown in these dots in
yellow here that only had a partial B cell depletion
across time. Interestingly, and this lines up actually very closely
with the published ex vivo autologous study performed in
macaques,
we see recovery of the B cell populations between days 35
and 49. We've looked at this carefully and mechanistically to
understand what is driving that recovery.
And as I introduced, it is a Lu16scFv human,
sorry, murine scFv on a human CAR backbone.
So what we see is actually quite a potent anti-CAR immune
response that arises in the monkeys, directed against both a
Lu16scFv as well as some of the human components in the
hinge and endodomains.
So, the recovery of B cells directly correlates with the
arising anti-CAR response, and even with complete depletion, we see this
response, so quite striking. This was also observed, again, in the
lymphodepleted animals that received ex vivo autologous CAR T cells in
that Fred Hutch Children's publication earlier.
So one area that I think
we're working on very closely is understanding the immunogenicity,
both of the lentiviral vector particles as well as the CAR
constructs, because we are going into fully immune competent patients,
and that'll be an important consideration for all in vivo CAR T cell approaches
moving forward.We've also very
carefully characterized the
toxicology and biodistribution of our Vivovect particles and the
resultant CAR T cells. In this non-human primate macaque study, the animals were
necropsied at day 91 post-administration.
And what we observed is low levels of detectable transgene
in tissues predominantly enriched for immune cells, so liver
and lymphoid tissue. And those are predominantly CAR T
cells with a small fraction of CAR macrophages.
Not surprisingly there, because we know macrophages are so good at
scavenging particles and resulting in transduction.
But generally, a very favorable biodistribution profile at a very late time point,
and these are low copy numbers. We've furthered this
analysis to get down to the cell type specific level with in situ
hybridization and find, again, that the very low level of
transduction that we observed at these late time points
are CAR T cells with a small population of CAR macrophages.
And
the biodistribution of these cells likely relates to the trafficking
properties of the immune cells. So not surprising we're seeing them where we're
seeing them.
Furthermore, the administration and the CAR expansion was very well tolerated.
We did not see any adverse pathological
findings related to the particles, and there was some
low-grade transient CRS that occurred during peak CAR T cell
expansion
that resolved quite quickly. Importantly, what we did
not observe is dramatic infusion-related toxicities that
has been published recently with some of the BCMA-targeted in vivo CAR products.
So that will be a super important area to keep an eye on related to
particle design and manufacturing and also particle dosing
as the field matures.
So
I did want to spend just a brief moment describing sort of the
modularity of our technology platform and the ability to not only
incorporate a CAR system, but also incorporate
armoring and/or potency enhancing technology.
Another aspect that I think will be important, whether it's ex vivo,
auto, allo, and/or in vivo approaches, a CAR alone
is likely not going to be sufficient to drive durable responses
in oncology indications, certainly as we get into more challenging
oncology indications. We've developed a synthetic cytokine
receptor called RACR. It stands for rapamycin activated cytokine
receptor. It's encoded within the payload and expressed alongside the
CAR construct. It's a drug-on system.
So our in vivo engineered CAR T cells express this RACR
system.
In the presence of rapamycin, it drives a STAT5
signal akin to IL-2 or IL-15 selectively to the in
vivo engineered T cells.
So this is simply rapamycin binding domains fused to the
signaling domains of IL-2
receptor beta and gamma.
And again, a drug-on system, so you can withdraw rapamycin, and the signal will
wane consistent with the half-life of rapamycin.
We've modeled this extensively in vivo and are now using
this system in our clinical trials as well, using that same Nalm6
model, in this case, an anti-CD22 CAR construct.
Nalm6s are known to be CD22 low, so this is a great
model to evaluate the ability of a potency enhancing
technology to overcome low antigen levels,
in this case, in the Nalm6 model in the same humanized mouse I introduced earlier.
The particles are introduced
in the
tumor-bearing humanized animals, and then we track them over time.
One cohort was left untreated, so no rapamycin.
That's our monotherapy cohort. The other cohort was treated with rapamycin to
engage the RACR system. And you can see right away dramatic
and preferential expansion across the various particle dose
levels of the anti-CD22 CARs enabled by engaging the
RACR system relative to what appears to
be this early transient peak of CAR T cells, and then
waning thereafter in response to a low CD22 antigen
tumor. This translates to quite profound anti-tumor
activity in the vast majority, and this is the lowest Vivovect particle
dose. We call this VV400. Same study as before, looking at
the tumor burden in these animals.
You see sort of transient control at the low dose.
Most of the animals relapse and succumb to tumor burden, wherein
the animals that receive rapamycin, potentiating
the CAR T cell expansion and persistence, the vast majority of them
actually clear the tumor with the exception of one, which had very high tumor
burden at the beginning. So a very impressive benefit
of engaging that pro-survival signal selectively to our in vivo CAR
T cells.
So I'll briefly highlight the fact that there's
some very important elements to consider when developing an in vivo CAR T
cell therapy, surface engineering, and payload components
being key areas to think about. There's a number of different bells and
whistles that we've heard about today that can be implemented.
I highlighted Emoja's multi-domain fusion and RACR system being
key.
We've leveraged, and I provided sort of a survey of our non-clinical data
that we've used to now enable our first in human clinical trials
that are in flight. We have our own internal manufacturing that are supporting all
of our clinical trials based in Colorado.
And our three active clinical trials are highlighted here in the top three rows.
VV111 targeting CD19 incorporates our RACR technology
in NHL and CLL. This is the first open IND in the
US for an in vivo CAR T cell therapy with a great
collaboration with our partners at AbbVie.
We have a clinical trial with the VV400 product that I just described the
non-clinical data from. That's a RACR anti-CD22 CAR payload in
non-Hodgkin's lymphoma, currently enrolling in a China
IIT.That same CAR construct without the racer
is being
tested in a China IIT in autoimmune disease, SLE specifically.
The thinking there is you don't necessarily need persistent CAR T cells.
You need rapid and deep depletion of B cells achieving an immune reset,
and then you want the B cells to recover.
VV500 will actually have a preclinical poster presented at
ASGCT in a few weeks in multiple myeloma,
leveraging a lot of the tandem design ideas that Remus highlighted
earlier. We have a program in solid tumors and then a number of
active discovery projects together, again, with our great partners at AbbVie.
So with that, I will close, and I'd be happy to take any questions.
And if there are questions about the other talks too, please feel free to speak up.
Thank you all.
Okay, are there...
Thank you.
David Barrett from Kite. That was a whirlwind tour of a lot of topics, and you
all talk really fast. So thank you for getting through so much in so short a
time.
I have
numerous questions that could take us forever, but I think one of the big ones is,
with solid tumors particularly,
the T cells need to move. They have to get into the solid tumor environment.
They've got to be able to do that, and I think for the in vivo technology, how are
we going to get them to move? You're transducing them where they are at.
If it's an immune-excluded tumor, there are no T cells in it.
What's the strategy there? And then for the ex vivo and even the gamma delta
approaches,
we've seen with mesothelin and other things, even if you give them very close
by, it's very difficult to get them in there, and just what your
thoughts are on how your technologies could apply that problem.
So I'll start.
So I think that's an extremely important question.
And because I didn't talk fast enough, I didn't quite highlight that on my
final slide. My final slide said we need more innovation around
delivery, and I think that's what you're getting at as well.
I think delivery of these cell products is going to be key.
So I think we need innovation. I think there are people out there that are working
on it in the biotech,
in the bioengineering field. So I think some of these innovations are
coming, but not fast enough. So I think that's
going to be a key. I think Remus mentioned some of the things that he thought were
big in the future that need to be done.
I forgot to mention that, and I think delivery is one of them, and I wish more
people would work on it. Do you want to add?
Sure. It's good to see you, Dave.
I think just like we spend a lot of time defining the target on the tumor, we have
to find the target in the tumor microenvironment.
And the point I try to make is that adding the CAR into the system changes the
tumor microenvironment. So it's not enough to just do an at diagnosis.
You have to look at throughout the treatment arc what's happening at TME.
I think the good news is, I'm hoping, at least according to disease, that this
is not going to be as variable, right?
Because we're having endogenous myeloid and fibroblast-like cells
responding. We just have to know which ones they are. And we may not need a CAR.
We might do LNP delivery. There's lots of redirecting ways.
So I think we spend a lot of time doing CARs.
I think now we have to figure out how we're going to modify that base to make a
dent into solid tumors.
Yeah, I would just add on top of what's already been said is the
heterogeneity is a huge challenge.
So combinatorial targeting is an area that we're focusing on with
what we call a universal CAR construct.
And furthermore, the potentiation of the
function in trafficking via cytokine signaling, whether it's
a STAT5-like signal or an IL-18-like signal,
at least in pre-clinical models, looks very promising in solid tumors.
And, I'm optimistic some of the ex vivo autologous
companies like Arsenal and others are able to show off some of their
great STAT induction driving
anti-tumor activity in solid tumor. So I think there's a lot out there.
We're focusing on combinatorial targeting of the TME currently.
Yeah, but it's also interesting that Lily Yang is standing right next to you, and
she's working on metallic proteases-
Yeah
... and trying to break down the tumor microenvironment to get more T cells into
it. So it's...
Jürgen Schmitz, MedImmune Biotech. Short question to Dr. Larson.
How sure can you be that the MDF of your Vivotek
platform with the CD80, CD58,
and the CD3 triggering
domains works the same in macaques as in
humans? Same affinities or something?
Yeah. So
I glossed over this. We did have to adapt the MDF.
Specifically, we used a NHP reactive anti-CD3
scFv because the one we employ in our human products
doesn't cross-react. So great question.
We did look carefully at the human
and macaque CD58 and CD80. They are
essentially
the same, and they function the same.
So the only change we made was to the scFv.
Thank you.
Okay, I'm going to read a couple that came in off the internet real fast.
What advantage do gamma delta T cells have over NK cells, given that you
show that NK cells may be better? And,
honestly, I've always thought NK cells should be doing better than they are,
but they're not. So,
I think we haven't quite cracked the nut on how to utilize these or what
targets are best. But for NK cells, you still have the killer
immunoglobulin receptors that might be problematic on HLA
targeting, where you don't have those with gamma delta T cells.
And I think gamma delta T cells are easier to expand than NK cells, even though if
you're an NK lab, you might disagree with that.
Another one-
Quick thing. Yeah.
Okay.
We obviously have a Prodigy-based gamma delta, especially a delta nine
expansion, and
NKs come along for the ride. They're only about 5% to 10% of the product.
They transduce really nicely, maybe better than gamma adults, and they do add a
lot. So actually, we like the quasi mix.
I do too.
Yeah.
I love it. I don't know how when you go to the FDA with a product, it's
like, okay, we said minimum NK is like 20%.
That was what we told the FDA when we do our expansion.
So if we go outside of that, you can't use it, even though I think 50/50 would be
great. But how do you manufacture that? So that's going to be a concern.
With courage.
Okay, we're getting a lot online, so let's speed up a little bit.
Okay.
Really?
Thank--
Yeah.
Thanks. Okay.
Okay. Oh, you can go ahead. Women. Okay, let's go.
Thanks to all the three speakers for the elegant presentations.
The question is from the last presentation.
So we see on an average 38 to 40, around 40%
transduction in the in vivo system.
So,
my question is, is there a subset of T cells
that is transduced preferentially in terms of
effector function on the naive T cells?
Do we know, is there any preferential transduction?
Yeah, it's a great question. I think what we have seen is,
and we've designed specifically to not drive preferential
transduction because we want to engage the diversity of T cell
populations. So that's kind of the reason we included the CD58,
CD2 axis into our MDF, because there are a number
of T cell populations, in particular in patients, that don't express
CD28.
And also we see very similar transduction, for example, between
CD4s and CD8s, effector memory, central memory
subsets therein.
It's going to be somewhat variable as we get into
patient populations who have very heterogeneous T cell populations, and we wanted
to create something that was going to be able to engage the diversity of T cells
to minimize that variability. That comes with other
implications, in terms of the quality of the different T cell subsets,
but,
generally, we don't see that much selectivity.
Thank you.
Yep.
So then an online question: Do you think you're going to transduce NK cells with
CD2?
Great question. We definitely see
NK cell particle binding driven by the CD58, CD2
interaction. We do not see transduction of NK cells.
If we did, it would be good, I think.
Back to the NK discussion. If it happened, it would be great, honestly.
But we don't see very much of it.
Vincent?
Okay. So I have a question in terms of in vivo CAR T cell.
Can you speak into the mic? We can't hear.
So right now, when you do systemic delivery, what is the
common most
place to produce this CAR T cells? So if you
deliver virus or nanoparticle,
liposome deliver, mostly they go to liver and spleen, and they
don't... So when they generate CAR, do they go to lymph node?
The
tumor will be the ideal site. So
for example, if we can generate some
deliver vehicle can target a specific organ, what is the ideal place you
want the CAR T to be?
Your journey from lymph node to injection.
Yeah, it's a great question. I don't think we know the answer to that,
right? So I think in an ideal world, we put the
particles in the blood, and they immediately find the T cells in the blood.
I think that's not the whole story.
The interesting thing that we see is,
I think of the particle surface engineering as a T cell engager.
So, after we dose the animals, we see rapid
demargination of peripheral T cells into the tissue, which I think
is beneficial, in that you're driving T
cells into tissue where their cognate antigen is.
So back to the question about solid tumors, that's a good thing.
If it's a lymphoma, you want the T cells to be in the
lymphoma tumor where their antigen is.
So, in terms of where it's all happening, is
transduction sort of enriched in certain areas? We don't know the answer to that.
It's something we're looking at, though.
Okay. Thank you.
Yeah, great question.
Okay.
Question for Ryan as well.
There are already some safety concerns using lenti system for
ex vivo transduced products.
Though the
safety is on the lower side, less than 1% of the patients show
T cell lymphoma. But in case of in vivo system using
a lentivirus
targeted for T cells, do you think the safety concern is going to be higher?
And the virus is going to persist, known, that's why
people have HIV.
And those patients don't develop insertional oncogenesis-driven
cancer. I think is probably the key point.
It's a theoretical risk in my mind.
So the less than 1% of subjects that experience
a transduced second malignancy generally
have another driving mutation that perhaps
cooperatively a malignancy arises.
But there's no evidence in my knowledge that there is a
vector alone driven insertional oncogenesis event that's
driven a second malignancy. And remember, those are in CAR T
cell manufacturing processes that typically employ very
high MOIs and very high resultant VCN per
CAR T cells.
The MOIs that we're achieving in vivo in a patient are
minuscule. So I think the risk of a
resultant T cell malignancy is extremely low.
Far lower, actually, than ex vivo manufactured CAR T cells.
Okay. Thank you.
Have you looked at integration profiling?
Yeah, it's the same. It's a typical lenti.
It's just lower, because the MOIs we're achieving are so low.
I think the last 5Y MTR data has been like 60,000 CAR T
cell patients globally. Is that the right number?
Yep.
Yeah. So, if we were seeing a significant oncologic
risk-We far exceeded the numbers we received.
Yes.
And actually, FDA pulled back on the black box warning somewhat.
So yeah,
exactly.
This takes 10 years.
Great presentations today. I enjoyed all three very much. Thank you.
Mikhail Logan from System Air. I'm a sucker for
targeted gene
delivery, so I have a question for Ryan.
In my postdoc, I did a side experiment where I decorated a
serotype lentivirus with two different targeting
varieties. One of them is classic VSVG, and the other one
was
spike protein targeting ACE2. So I was curious,
if that virus would transduce non-ACE2 cells,
and not to my surprise, I noticed there was some
non-specific transduction as well.
So I was curious
if you looked into endothelial cells having CAR expression, or
I saw some NHP data that is less than
0.1%, I think, in some tissues. But I was curious about
endothelial CAR expression in the injection site.
Yeah, great question. So we don't see any evidence of
non-immune cell transduction. The cell types that we see being
transduced are T cells and rare macrophages.
And
there's actually extensive literature around administration of
VSVG pseudotyped vectors in monkeys and mice and otherwise, where they
see hepatocyte transduction and in all sorts of LDLR-positive
cells being transduced.
Those are extremely high doses,
often two to three orders of magnitude above what we're
delivering in our animal and even in our human studies.
The element that we're really leveraging is the ability to dose
far lower than what those studies performed and the fact that
the engineered T cells will expand because that's what T cells do.
We don't need to go in at a high dose to increase the
risk. There's also a lot of really great
biology around
different approaches to pseudotyping viral vectors.
Sounds like you've worked on that a bit in terms of mutating different
components on the VSVG or the co-cat or otherwise to block
LDLR interactions. Whether or not those
become key differentiators, I think is TBD.
We've found detriments to doing that, to our pseudotyping,
with no risk of off-target transduction with a wild-type
pseudotype.
But the space is what we'll learn, there's a lot of opportunities to learn.
Gotcha.
Do you have any pediatric studies planned?
We currently are not planning any pediatric studies,
but that will definitely become part of any late-stage development campaign.
It'll be a requirement, so once we get into late stage.
Transduction changes will-
Yep
... off-target change.
I have a second question. You have three different
antibodies and also the
fusion protein on the surface of the lentiviral particles.
So I was curious about the redosability of the technology here.
Redosability, yeah. So I think that speaks to the immunogenicity
aspect, too. The intent is to
single-dose drive CAR T cells that are able to persist if they
need to persist and drive a durable response with a single dose.
We have modeled
redosing in monkeys, and our RACR system actually enables that
because we're using rapamycin as immunosuppressants to give the particles and the
CAR T cells cover
by suppressing the anti-particle and anti-CAR responses.
So that's another differentiating aspect of our RACR
technology that others don't have, is that we may be able to
redose if needed.
Although that's not the goal. Hopefully, it's a single dose, one and done.
I see, yeah. Because CAR T, it's going to stay there.
Okay, let's go to the next-
Oh, so sorry.
We're almost out of time.
Thank you.
Really great talk.
I think I have probably a few quick questions.
So, the first question is,
with the efficacy we saw in Cota cells, so do you think
if we found probably a good antigen for a specific cancer type,
then do you think it's worthwhile to probably design tandem strategy
to target multiple epitopes in the same antigen?
And my second question is regarding the probably tonic
signaling. So in your presentation, you have shown that it seems that
for at least for your Cota-like CAR T, so seem that they have
higher tonic signaling, and they're associated with better
efficacy. But we also know for excessive tonic signaling,
it's related to probably immature exhaustion and probably failure of
treatment. So currently, do we have a clear criteria to
say where is the optimal
range for tonic signaling for CAR T manufacturing? Thanks.
No, I think that's exactly-- It's interesting that the VHHs seem to work better in
this tandemized format. I haven't formalized what the
exact on/off rates for each VHH are.
We're just doing it at a mass screening, but I think the better your screen, the
better your result. In general, SCFEs are easier to get in display
libraries. They seem to be more natural in terms of binders.
VHHs, when you get a good one, you get a really good one, but they tend to be super
sticky. Lots of them seem to stick to everything, so you have to have a lot
broader campaign and screen a lot more off-target effects
of the VHHs. The tandemization, I think this is
the kind of the secret sauce that Legend showed us first, right?
Yeah.
Thanks.
And when you're making bites, it's the same thing.
They just muck up the cells when you're trying to express them.
Okay. I'm Hua from SPH Biotherapeutics.
I have a question for Rimas, maybe for Ryan.
So Rimas, you did a very good talk. I always
enjoy your talk.
But in the speech you mentioned, so Terry
Fry discover CD92 CAR,
that CD22 will
down-regulate when treated with 22 CAR, right?
But
that's why many company maybe abandon the CD22 CAR.
However, in the Amgen case, they still play huge bet
on the CD22 CAR in the imevio. So how
do you reconcile this?
Is it because the binder from different antibody
have different impact on this phenomenon?
Well, I'll give a quick answer in terms of in pediatrics.
I mean, Raleigh has a pretty large series, Hua, and
it's very effective, right? So when we see the
relapses, it's just for a different reason, right? It's for the down modulation.
Not all down modulations happen.
Should it stand as a single product? I think that's kind of a development question.
Mm-hmm.
If I can get the same effect with the 1922, that's kind of what I'm going to
develop.
Yeah, right.
Yeah, and from a development perspective, there is still a significant unmet need
in patients that have failed 19-based systems, and now you're seeing
the emergence of the 19 by 20 targeting approach.
It becomes a patient population that doesn't have any other options once they've
failed a 19 alone or a 19 by 20 CAR.
So the way we've thought about it is that patient still needs an
option, and also we're trying to develop a differentiated technology to
overcome some of the known liabilities of CD22 targeting.
Namely, the racer system. We have an optimal CAR construct, it's
not M971,
that we think is differentiated there as well.
Okay, great.
Yep.
So another last question for Ryan.
Do you have the timeline to release China IIT data?
We're optimistic that we'll have some data disclosures by the
end of this year.
Oh, okay. Great.
One quick question there. Turning off our computer up here or playing with
it, so.
We got to turn off the lights.
Yeah, I know.
Thanks for the speaker. So I have a question for Ryan.
You mentioned in your-
Of course, it's Ryan
... imevio CAR engineering, there's some off-targeting
for the macrophage. So how you see that off-targeting
engineering of a macrophage with your CAR?
Is it
potentially, especially in a tumor-like treatment scenario,
is that could be beneficial because of your combo or-
Yeah
... potentially
I actually don't see it as off target.
I see it as whatever we want to call it. I see it as beneficial.
I would highlight, though, if you compared the magnitude of
macrophage transduction to what we see at peak CAR T cell levels on day seven to
day 10, it's minuscule, right? You can't measure it by
flow cytometry. The only way you can measure it is very sensitive in situ
hybridization. So it's probably not a meaningful magnitude
of macrophage transduction. It's just an observation at this point.
The dominant driver for activity is absolutely the CAR T cell
population in the monkeys or the animals and ultimately in people.
Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. Thank you.
Okay. Well, we'd like to thank everyone for staying this long, and it
shows that it's an important topic.
Thank you very much